another great aspect of starting a
podcast is encouraging that learning as
a collective is super super powerful and
underestimated another really cool thing
about starting a podcast and what I've
experienced which i think is really
really cool which I wanted to share was
learning as a collective is is so so
powerful and I think to be fair it's a
lot more talked about now because I
think the sort of mindset of don't know
how many generations ago from honest I'd
be lying if I didn't know but I feel
like for me the older generation had the
sort of mindset of don't turn you on our
secrets don't tell you on our secrets we
don't want them to know what we're doing
I would be there don't want anyone to
know what what we're doing sort of thing
but so many people talk about it now and
I think it's amazing where we can all
learn from each other there's so much
opportunity out there there's enough to
go around
and I think having the mindset of no no
I don't want anyone to know obviously in
terms of business and stuff like that
there's stuff that you don't want to
share but I think with this podcast I
think it's really shown especially in
the industry that I'm in recruitment is
that we really can learn as a collective
and we can learn from each other and I
think I'm really I'm realizing it
because I am learning from the guys that
I get on my show and it's it's really
really fun and I think hopefully people
can see that when they listen to the
episodes that hopefully they can learn
as well and I think that encouraging the
sort of learning as a collective really
really is a great thing and I think this
it's even more and more encouraging now
and spoken about but that's one of the
sort of realizations I have with this
podcast is that we have so much to give
to each other and so we can learn from
each other's mistakes and I think that
to sort of grow and be successful as a
collective
is an amazing amazing thing and
hopefully I'm hoping this podcast can
sort of encourage that mindset and also
just in encourage those behaviors
[Music]